[موسيقى]
مرحبًا ، أنا دكتور سانجاي جوبتا مضيف
بودكاست مطاردة الحياة على قناة سي إن إن ، كما تعلم في
الصيف الماضي ، لقد تم تذكيرني بأنه لا يوجد
شيء أفضل من الوصول إلى الطريق المفتوح
وأيضًا لا يوجد شيء أسوأ من حركة المرور في
الواقع لقد تم إخباري في عام 2021 بأن السائقين الأمريكيين
فقدوا  في المتوسط ​​36 ساعة لحركة المرور
كل ذلك الوقت في السيارة يمكن أن
يتسبب في خسائر ، مما يؤدي إلى انخفاض النشاط البدني
وارتفاع ضغط الدم وبالطبع الكثير
من الإجهاد
المروري يقول عالم النفس دوايت
هينيسي لهذا السبب من المهم أن تشعر
بالراحة ونعم الهدوء
على  ربما تبدأ الطريق بالاستماع إلى
موسيقاك المفضلة أو البودكاست المفضل لديك ،
أحضر مساعدًا للطيار يمكن أن يساعد في
إبعاد عقلك عن ضغوط الطريق
وأخذ لحظة خاصة إذا كنت في طريق
توقف حركة المرور لتقدير
الجمال الطبيعي الذي قد تكون عليه  انظر طوال رحلتك ،
ابحث عن المتعة في هذا النشاط اليومي ،
ومع ذلك يمكنك القيام بذلك ،
يمكنك سماع المزيد حول كيفية تحسين
صحتك ومطاردة الحياة أينما
تحصل على البودكاست الخاص بك